ville 2019 et gilet jaune défilent à
paris lors d'une manifestation autorisée
mélanie une militante occupée à lire un
tract ne voit pas la charge de crs
derrière son dos elle est alors
violemment frappé par surprise par un
crs et elle s'effondre elle nous raconte
je suis seul où j'ai les bras levés j'ai
le papier dans la main un homme fait 28
pas donc cours sur 30 mètres arme son
bras et massène un coup de matraque dans
la nuque
ces images signalé par le journaliste et
écrivain david dufresne provoque
l'indignation sur les réseaux sociaux
elles vont être visionnée plus d'un
million de fois mélanie travailleuse
sociale et porte-parole des gilet jaune
damien les réfractaires du 80 se
souvient le père connaissance à
plusieurs reprises je dirais 3 à 4 fois
que je me souviens de la douleur et je
me souviens d'après la douleur j'ai eu
une entorse des cervicales
j'ai les disques c4 et c5 qui sont morts
la légiste m'a dit que si jamais je
n'avais pas eu cette écharpe
je serai tétraplégique à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui pour moi c'était même pas
envisageable que ce soit un homme qui
ait fait ça délibèrement je ne pouvais
pas l'imaginer parce que moi j'ai grandi
dans une famille où on nous a donné des
valeurs de respect qu'un uniforme ça se
respecte et cette mère de famille porte
plainte contre x
mais surprise début janvier le parquet
de paris classé la plainte sans suite
selon la justice le choix du policier
dollar poussée lors de sa charge était
justifiée même si la blessure subie
n'était pas recherché
il a en outre jugé que la vitesse de
marche de la gilet jaune
allez la laisser derrière le nouveau
barrage qu'ils essayaient d'établir ce
qui était dangereux
cette décision a révolté plusieurs
personnalités et bien entendu mélanie
dans mon éducation de quartiers
populaires c'est ce qu'on m'a appris ce
que mon père m'a transmis qui ne court
pas tu n'as rien fait mélanie tu ne
cours pas il ya que les délinquants qui
courent et que ceux qui ont quelque
chose à se reprocher qui courent
moi je cours je la mets si jamais rien à
me reprocher en fait mais il ya un
recours on va aller jusqu'au bout on va
les saigner les recours tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire on le fera
mon but c'est pas de gagner de l'argent
c'est juste que quand une personne ne
tape le nom de mon agresseur dans google
y est pas toutes ses médailles parce
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
était même médaillé au mois de mai
mélanie affirme connaître l'identité du
crs en question le milieu militant crois
qu'il s'agit d'un homme déjà connu pour
des faits similaires il est important
que la police est une vraie police pour
les juger aujourd'hui en policier qui
lance un pavé qui ne touche personne
prend trois mois avec sursis
qu'on m'accuse s'il fallait condamner
quelqu'un c'était une personne qui avait
blessé un manifestant un militant cette
militante n'est pas découragé de
manifester et continuer à fédérer les
gilet jaune d'amiens pour elle il est
nécessaire de ne pas plier devant la
peur au nom du combat pour la justice
sociale